ضربات صاروخيه جديده على البنيه التحتيه
في اوكرانيا شملت ميناء اوديسي الجنوبي
والعاصمه تكييف ومدينه دنيبر وسط البلاد
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اكدت ان القوات
الروسيه قصفت مصنع ينتج مواد لاصلاح محطات
الرادار التابعه للجيش الاوكراني
ومحركات الصواريخ القوات الاوكرانيه في
مدينه
ايضا تدمير ورش العمل في مجمع الابحاث
الذي انتج مكونات الكترونيه لاصلاح محطات
الرادار وقذفات الصواريخ المتعدده
ما لا يقل عن 23 شخصا كما الحق اضرارا
بمبنا صناعي ومجمع سكني وسياره قريبه
شكرا عندما سقط الصاروخ كنت استعد للعمل
مع زوجي منزلنا الان بلا نوافذ ولم يبقى
لدينا زجاج سليم
[موسيقى]
للعدو ان يضرب مره اخرى الموقع الذي يعمل
فيه رجال الانقاذ وايضا نظرا لوجود اضرار
في الهياكل فهناك خطر كبير على رجال
الانقاذ لانه قد يكون هناك انهيار للمبنى
الجنه
ما احدث شللا في البناء التحتيه
الاوكرانيه للطاقه في وقت تتساقط الثلوج
في البلاد مع بدء الشتاء